ihre söhne wir für euch alle auch wenn
du dich mit chipkarten viel mit
vorschlägen und das ist so krass und
hallo meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft faro auf dem server ich
bin weiter in einer höhle suche hier
diamanten damit auch der kinos sich eine
complete die aris zu machen kann und bei
mir wird ja immer in den kommentaren
gesagt spark und selbst die haben ja
wohl die wahrheit kommt jetzt punktes
achtung converter rap 30 gibt gebiet
geben ihre söhne wir für euch alle auch
wenn du dich mit chipkarten viel mist
vorschlägen sind und dass es so krass
und was ich da mal sagen weil ich hab
das jetzt schon antwortet allem ein
immer sehr wahr freut ihr euch dann über
jeden scheiß diamanten so das barcode
selbst in ihrem laufen im wandel zeigt
keine regung diesem foul aber es gibt
auch branchen ist ja kaum diamant es
gibt welche die haben bisher so zwei
diamanten oder so und wir freuen uns
einfach dass wir überhaupt noch am leben
sind weil unser ziel war dass wir nicht
in der ersten folge sterben
das zeigt ja wie wie optimistisch wieder
am anfang des weges zur freude
deswegen freuen uns jetzt über jeden
scheiß den wir hier irgendwie in diesem
projekt erreichen
deswegen verstehe ich nicht warum jeder
immer weiter freut euch doch mal nicht
schön wenn wir immer emotionen zeigen
hier mein ich glaub ich glaub ich glaube
irgendwie kann das anders bei den tannen
also ich bin die ganze bei den pandas
tage keine äpfel rauskommen sinnlos denn
ganz hellen räumen kann das sein
ich probiere es auch bei den herren war
hier irgendwie nie was passiert bei den
helmen birken ja ja genau es gibt ja
gibt ja es gibt diese tannen mäßigen
bäumen und bei dem planmäßigen beim
hatte ich bisher kein glück deswegen
diesmal zurück
das hat sich im hotel geräumt da weil
richter übrigens liebe war en news
twitter seite damit du nicht mehr so ein
aufwand hat kontra fda und verkehrs und
jeder nur an meinen dafür kannst ja
machen du bist jetzt sehr innovativ was
ist hier anschauen
die letzten einfach wieder nur mal
wieder normal aber gestern war finden
aber im laufenden band diamanten also
ich habe zweimal diamanten gefunden dass
am laufenden band ist alles cool
also ich habe das gefühl da guckst du
nur das projekt trotz gibt es ein
bisschen
georgen augen ja ich weiß es besser und
ich bin da wirklich alle folgen schauen
würde ist das natürlich schon eine ganz
schön deftig birma wo bin ich denn jetzt
endlich wieder runter gesprungen ist
starke gute zusammenfassung in beiden
rollen macht sich ein jahr später das
ist das einzige was in dieser folge
passierte bei teamradio hättet ihr saß
die ganze zeit da und da musste man das
crafting rezept ausprobieren was ja das
nicht hinbekommen für das schwer
deswegen ging das soll die ganze
folgende mich jetzt mal minecraft
angefangen ja richtig zornig macht das
noch nicht so lange da müsst ihr jetzt
auch ein bisschen nachsichtig sein dass
du viel mit dem fitnessstudio
beschäftigt ich habe 22
flint das hat schon mal 22
ich muss jetzt ich muss jetzt auch echt
level fahren dass ich mir hier so
langsam diese schärfe 3 die aps machen
kann
aber ich würde mich wichtig dieser
schärfe drei die abwehrstärke dann kann
ich endlich so effizienz 1 alles klappt
eigentlich aber egal ich mach das mal
alles hier rein was kann ich denn der
verein wächst denn eigentlich das
zuckerrohr ist weg
ich bin professionelle bodybuilder aber
müssen am ende dieser episode wieder
umziehen oder ich würde sogar sagen dass
eventuell noch eine dritte aufnehmen
dürfen weil der drei im voraus hast ja
sicher dass wir dürfen nie weil die war
die antwort ist nicht anderes einfach
nicht an
damit ist man ein bisschen warm ist
meint episode uns wird schon wieder
verabschieden
umziehen deswegen will ich sagen ich
komme minute zehn grad ich mich einfach
nach oben dann bin ich zum mini 12
irgendwie oben ich gehe ich gehe auch
ein bisschen ich ja auch ein bisschen
meinen ich komme ich komm runter zu dir
gegangen ja ja ich weiß ich habe so eine
riesige höhle gefunden hat ist
unglaublich
die einfach auch in die höhe und
besuchte ein paar gänge die noch und
erkundet sind drop sie einfach richtig
mach mal nach mainz tritt mein system
dann macht das wird mein system damit
sich keine jammern
deswegen ist wegen fall aber ich habe
ich auch eine wilde gefunden also ich
sag deine wer nach fackeln
hasso für travel schaufel ja ich habe
keine scharfen aber mit fackeln kriegst
du glaub ich kein flint
ich möchte aber ich möchte aber auch gar
kein gremmel habe ich will vielleicht
aber eigentlich genug ich habe 37 will
der sollte eigentlich reichen
ich will nach unten ich mache meine
spitzhacke konnte euch ab sofort mit
mannheimer den dreck ab dazu mit dem ein
arbeitet sie erst ab hier habt ihr
gefunden mache ich kaputt dass er dass
das wären spaß ich glaube da würdet ihr
euch alle sehr freuen und uns bestimmt
als favoriten für die nächstjährigen
dummheit wahlen zum heizen einreichen
kommentare auf höchstem niveau manche
finden kein halten mehr
aber jetzt müsste eigentlich commerce
gesagt habe ja ich muss ich muss ich
muss meinen diamanten song singen aber
das muss ich erstmal schön auf die höhe
und dann ist das ist das ist das
überhaupt ob du ich bin da ja mal
anfangen
ich nehme auch gold mit norwegen den
äpfeln einfach ja mach dass wir müssen
einfach nur irgendein apple finden
bisher sind wieder ein deutscher ist der
name uns ok du bist in dem stück mein
system nur dann kann ich einfach zu dir
kommen nach hause
ja ja eigentlich wahrscheinlich schon
was wollt was wollte ich guck mal hier
vorbei schneehöhle nicht mehr wahr
also ich weiß dass ich bin froh dass ich
schon die sechs diamanten gefunden so
schalten wir ja gar nicht sagen aber ich
finde einfach immer weniger so ich bin
in diesem jahr hohen gang hier ja ich
sag das wort redstone und sowas absacker
können immer viele diamanten seiner das
bilde ich mir mal so ein drehen
da könnte portillo heißt ein
ich bin gerade auch alaba bei hier ich
glaube ich eher weniger auf alle
möglichen herz aber keine diaz aber ich
bin auf y ich hatte noch nie
diese behinderten silberfische 11 weiß
ich bin direkt neben dem lama ding
nichts an der seite zur absicherung und
das bauen einfach diese viecher und
greifen mich an des todesangst pass auf
deswegen die nur mit dem wassereimer
voran al balawi stimmt ich habe dabei
alter lasse sei aber richtig scheiße das
ist das soll ich vielleicht mal gleich
wieder an diesem jahr sei vor sich dazu
im alabama mit einer wasserturms hinter
mir okay gut ich dachte ja schon wer
macht hier die ganze lava kaputt aber
ich lege und kräfte wie ich bin hinter
dir du bist unter mir wäre hinter dem
wie man sowas gar direkt hinter mir
crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy [ __ ] liga
keine diamanten
ich bin ich bin auch nicht nur gold aber
das kann man ja auch gebrauchen für
später im rennen auch mit die erfahrung
die erfahrung in allem ist gerade
wichtig als 20 level alter stark ja ich
war 24 grad könnten auch gerne mal
verschoben und wie man sie nicht nur mit
strapsen und macht das mobil können wir
mal eine scheibe auf zypern
das kannst du nicht du es besser du bist
besser ausgerüstet ich habe alles immer
dabei das ist im thurgau wenn du jetzt
wenn man eine verzauberung klaus die ich
mir erarbeitet habe conny dann aber dann
habe aber ein problem schreibt du dein
abi klausur mit meinem nackten bloßen
beharrten hintern auf deinem tisch wer
akzeptiert akzeptiert und ist so cool ja
ok man merkt es ist morgens ja ich bin
auch wirklich mal einfach so dass wir
total verpeilt sind einfach auf die
uhrzeit eines meine meine meine augen
steht auch gerade irgendwie so je länger
ist es ja auch es ist of pop stehe wie
herrlich indes oft mein gott da wird ja
viel zu hell ja jahre alt einem sonst so
richtig in die fresse unglaublich man
sieht quasi nur meine augen so ist das
hier gerade einfach dieses licht drei
leute tage irgendwie immer noch ein
bisschen eisen wie viel minuten haben
wir noch zeit
acht minuten acht minuten gut dann komm
ich nämlich gleich zurück ich bin ein
bisschen gang weiter vielleicht schaffe
ich ja noch oft wehrmann moment ich sing
die j j j ich bin bitter hat wo früher
konnte man ja noch späten jetzt geht das
ja nicht mehr
das ist ja ist einfach nicht mehr
einfach nicht mehr raus genommen oder
wurde wurde rausgenommen das feature zum
einzigen lodge gott zu beten ich das
kann ja wohl nicht angehen dass ich
jetzt isch grad nix finden sie auch eine
folge jetzt nichts finden das jahr das
regt mich total auf weil das ist ja dann
total sinnlos die runtergegangen und
einfach nur einfach nur zeit
verschwendet eigentlich und einmal weg
gebaute geht wahrscheinlich wieder raus
aber ich mich noch mal kurz an die seite
kaum schauen was will ich denn mit eisen
so viel eisen ist gewillt mir schon aus
dem arsch das ist echt unglaublich ich
finde gerade auch keine die das alter
das ist ja mal richtig traurig ich kann
jetzt schon wieder den baron new street
jedoch von kräften sich die ganze
episode darüber auf dass die kleine
diamanten finden wie wir
wenn wir über dieses war en suite kann
ja ich ziehe nicht aber es ist ja ich
find's super auch wenn ich den nicht
volk ich finde es super dass das ist ja
ist ja eine schöne schöne update methode
okay ich hab ganz viel redstone gefunden
es gibt zumindest mal erfahrungen
das ist doch schon mal was wir können
auch mal können auch einfach random
irgendwo letzte und tnt fallenden baum
so einfach die sachen blues ist vor just
for fun
ich sehe hier so einen langen gang ich
bin bin ja wahrscheinlich bin ich in dem
langen gang irgendwo so jetzt was ist
hier schluss sein fordert decke gefallen
einfach mitnahm mit dem schlepper an
junge mutter erinnerte an die teams
borna
aber was aber auch nicht alles so ein
bisschen mehr hier jubeln für mich finde
ich ja geht also ich habe das meiner
mutter gesagt nicht hier bist du meine
mutter ist ein bisschen meine mutter
conny er sorry hab ich mir als
eingebildet aber ohne spaß das ist echt
grad traurig wird auch sagen jedes mal
mit einer auswahl ist es bricht die cdu
sagt das ist echt traurig dass wir
nichts finden und in dem moment schlage
ich den blog weg zu den diamanten ist
bibel sind war da mal komisch sind es
waren glaube ich fünf stücke oder so
letzter spitzer feder sind schön so gut
er ist einfach so unverschämt wie geil
das ist dann kann ich mir glaube ich
zumindest mal ein dia helm oder der
schule machen in der nächsten episode
und das ist verdammt geil somit aller
lang ja wahrscheinlich
du hast doch schon fast von liane du
brauchst du deine hose ja das ganz schön
cool so ist das mal gucken muss er denn
wieder rausgeht ich glaube hier irgendwo
oder nein als die komplette höhle ok
haben uns jetzt an wir uns jetzt
verlaufen wo ja wie ich glaube dass die
das ist das ist richtig wir müssen hier
lang ich weiß es sicher kaum nachkommen
abgemacht kommt nach weil ich hab hier
habe ich irgendwo ein eingang ihre wir
müssen die ruhe wieder finden
kannst du mal aufhören mir anderen ein
auf die fresse zu geben
guck mal hier geht's lang jedes mal
wieder hier mit seinem mag ihr system du
da das mache ich auch immer privat im
park wenn ich den weg zurückfinden muss
dann von etwas erhöht
nun erkundet am liebsten wenn ich die
einfach noch weiter auseinander nehmen
hier wir können natürlich auch mal da
bleibt glaube nicht dass jemand der
keine koordinaten gezeigt dass heißt du
bist du mann musste ich bin gerade hoch
laufen
das ist doch eingang wo bist du hin dann
lasst uns aber so ein paar wichtige
sachen auf jeden fall ins inventar noch
heute nehmen wir zum beispiel den höfen
haben oder so dann das kann man einfach
daran machen ist kein ding auch so oder
so nah dass das wäre ganz gut wenn das
so weiter wachsen würde ja das kann man
ja kann man ja eigentlich glaube nicht
ist ist echt man müsste unsere
kompletten wohnorte nachverfolgen und
wenn ihr ja schon relativ zeitig wieder
auf ja und können ja dann umziehen also
ich glaube dass einfach lass uns mal
lasst uns mal das risiko eingehen das
ist jetzt ein bisschen ich glaube dass
mal ok man kann jetzt war's schreiben
uns nicht um
ich war dass man übrigens ein bisschen
höher hier für das kann ja gar nicht so
richtig hart wachsen
ja ja das stimmt das stimmt da hab ich
mal wieder so ich kann mir auch mal
meine wasser einmal wieder für die lange
habe da noch zeit
vier minuten vier minuten okay das
reicht mir so ein bisschen entspannt
alles einzurichten dass ich mir mit den
letzten sieben diamanten eine hose
machen weil dann nicht komplett fulda
und du hast richtig da wir dann schon
mal ein hell macht ja mach du dir mach
dich frühjahr ist okay macht die studie
das auch noch ist der spitze es ist
einfach klasse was der diakonie in
seinen jungen jahren schon erreicht hat
ja sogar mit grandios was was für ein
mann und was für eine erotik und diese
person ausgeht ich finde jedoch nicht zu
passen
ich möchte einfach mit ihm schlafen so
wir wollen auch hier einfach noch eine
truhe hinstellen so zum spaß dass man
denkt so warcraft eine basis gefunden
ich mache das jetzt einfach mal alles
und dann ist das tag ich bin so froh
dass wir auch einfach mal diamanten du
hast eine full die abrüstung es ist
super ich finds auch
läuft es läuft es läuft auch in jeder
folge kann wir schreiben bei modeln
nicht so witzig rapper kommt folge elf
bei cdos und conny läuft richtig
unseriöse news so redet schmiede so ich
mache ja auch mal wenigstens den herrn
mit den dias fertig dann fehlen mir noch
viel mehr nur noch schuhe das heißt es
noch vier diamanten finden und dann ist
alles alles okay so kommt ihr auch nicht
auf schutz drauf ja es ist schön
lass mal ein paar unwichtige sachen was
dieser kiste rausnehmen das halt so ein
bisschen an sortieren dadurch aber dass
auf jeden fall unsere verzauberten
rüstungs sachen auch die alten
eisenteile in der kiste lassen weil wenn
das hat jemand findet und er ist noch
schlechter ausgesehen und weil bei uns
jetzt einfach alles das was soll s erde
da drin
sie sollte ich wollte weil sie mit ihm
vielleicht brauchen wir die erde wichtig
und ich habe dazu eine besondere
beziehung in meiner vergangenheit
gepflegt kann seinen spielstil michael
bully herbig ist so nah heran was wir
nicht brauchen
ich bin ich bin das war mal wieder ich
weiß gar nicht was sie machen ich bin
einfach nur so fasziniert von allem
ich bin so passiert von uns das ist von
uns genauso wir bleiben wir bleiben
jetzt hier ja das ist das ist disziplin
das wir dass wir gastgeber bleiben und
uns ein bisschen 1 1 von der von der
bühne chillen ja ein bisschen zweck und
bisschen hip hop ick hab mir mal den
flow richtig bluten lassen wenn man
seine specialities dem skill prüfen
möchte
das ist eine sache die finde ich werbe
geborsten for life hast du noch ein paar
pfeile für mich ja ich guck mal wie viel
wie viel hast du denn derzeit 2 gegen
angeblich in meine hälfte ab dann habe
ich 13 und ein bisschen mehr
ja aber da kann man doch eigentlich die
die folge auch schon fast wie andere
auch sagen wir haben jetzt mehrere
wichtigsten sachen gab es schnell ab
hier das ist das ist das dankeschön
amboss und in der nächsten ist sogar
varianten wechselt einfach weiter
das auch schön das ist auch gut in der
nächsten episode müssen wir gucken dass
ich halt noch meinem eine dia schule
bekommen und die 26 level um mein die
schwerter schärfe drei zu bringen ja und
dass ich am nächsten folgen mache also
ich habe jetzt meine komplette rüstung
ich habe komplett rüstungs punkte ich
will halt auch mal sperrten das messer
und natürlich sagen können wir dann auch
schon langsam ins kämpfen gehen
jaja und sehe ich hier keinen sinn noch
irgendwie weiter in der höhle zu gehen
weil ich habe komplett dir
okay okay okay alles klar gut genau
gesagt und würdig jahren mg und da gehen
wir raus jetzt das war eine schöne und
doch produktive episode obwohl ist
morgen war das rechtsamt hoch an
also schreibe am morgen aber wenn man
eine minute zeit hier also ab ich
schreibe morgen abi und danach hätte ich
eigentlich erst wieder danach hätte ich
das ein bisschen zeit danach
theoretisch folge 13 dann aufnehmen wenn
ein einzelner spieler auf dem server ist
und dann suchen wir den einfach mal und
wollen den abschnitt 24 7 vom rechner
muss man auch als und ja